you doing okay how can we help you
well I I'm calling on behalf of my
grandma who is 83 years old and he is
unable to move any of her limbs really
she is just laying there she could move
her facial muscles but she didn't smile
she can her eyes but she got anything
else okay now she get diagnosed with the
disease does she have a stroke does she
have an aneurysm does she have terminal
palsy I mean what does she got well um
the doctor said it could be a stroke she
had a stroke before many years ago about
20 plus years ago now do these symptoms
do these symptoms show up like overnight
or it was a gradual I would say it was
it was probably gradual I wasn't around
at the time but I heard she fell she
fell one day while walking and I don't
know if that triggered it
mm-hmm okay and how much does she weigh
you place about 150 there about 150
pounds okay all right does she have any
other issues and you high blood pressure
diabetes arthritis
yes hypertension high blood pressure
okay does she have any history of skin
problems eczema dermatitis psoriasis or
respiratory problems COPD asthma
no okay all right Charmaine you there
I'm here okay here's a 8 year old
grandmother 150 pounds she does have a
little bit of high blood pressure she
has a history of stroke and she's having
difficulties in moving her limbs can she
speak Aryan no she cannot okay
can she blink her eyes once for yes and
two for no kind of thing she couldn't
think ice but he cannot speak okay but
she couldn't understand what you're
saying and so she can respond with yes
or no with her eyes yes pretty much age
thing
okay good okay so Charmaine she weighs
150 pounds and I would pressure has had
a previous stroke and she did fall and
after her fall this sort of thing came
on her she can't move any of her limbs
and she cannot speak so what would you
do for her to support all her systems at
83 years of age well for those issues I
would suggest that she probably takes
two healthy brain and heart packs and
adds the ultimate daily classic to that
and I'll show some gluco gel and MSM and
vitamin d3 okay that's yeah that's a
good start yeah let's start there and so
I'll go over that again Freud Aryans
okay as you want to get her to healthy
been in heart attacks for months to
healthy brain and heart attacks month
the full dose everything twice a day the
gluco gel capsules going to get two
large vials of gluco gel capsules so she
could have 15 a day five at breakfast
five at lunch five at dinner you can
open up the capsules and put them in a
shake you have a wonderful shape called
slender FX if you make it with water
she'll lose weight we don't want to do
that you can make with a heavy whipping
cream and that way she may even gain a
little bit of weight and sustain your
weight but also that heavy whipping
cream is good for the brain and spinal
cord okay and I also want you to give
her a shower said the MSM you can brine
those tablets up and put them in that
shape one bottle of months we'll give
her three of those MSM tablets twice a
day vitamin d3 three capsules twice a
day those two bottles a month are if
there's a caregiver there who will spray
her mouth three Spitz's in the morning
trees first and evening we also have we
call the citrus vitamin D tree spray
okay so you have the choice of the spray
or the the capsules and then the
ultimate daily classic tablets support
healthy blood pressure as well as blood
flow healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries what would you give Charmaine
because she has a history of blood clots
you may still have some residual blood
clots and ruffles power cord and brains
what would you suggest for her that has
a capacity to dissolve blood clots I
would never take some niacin Plus okay
the ultimen I've someplace you're quite
correct I'd never go ahead and take and
you'd be a little heavy-handed here go
ahead and take one
three times a day one a breakfast my
lunch one to dinner or if that's too
clumsy take two twice a day and then you
know Brian him up and put him at her
shake and so the ultimate niacin plus
two bottles a month and call us every
two weeks call us anytime they're in but
you know don't wait longer than two
weeks to give us a progress or lack of
progress report